well he was the first golden knight big  number five he already lived here in las  vegas  but it was after one october derrick  england became a local sports hero  today the tough defenseman announced his  retirement england  played 11 seasons in the nhl including  the last three with the knights  but before his nhl career take off he  took off he of course played for the old  las vegas wranglers  met his wife settled in the valley few  fans will forget that speech on opening  night 2017 or the goal that he scored  afterwards  england now joins the vegas golden  knights foundation he will be special  assistant to the owner  don't worry angling going anywhere